[Music]  I've mentioned Holley T before right  [Music]  just something you need you know yeah  this is the guest room  Holly and I we fooled around us sex with  your college roommate it was a one-time  thing that happened five or six times  Wow you have a threesome opportunity in  your very near future I can't stop  thinking about it well make it happen if  she gets all right things get out of  control maybe a little control would be  good for us do you prefer having sex  with her  we're having sex with me with you took  too long to answer  it's not about Holly this was about us  no would like us to have a threesome I'm  totally into it how do you feel and  scale of 1 to 10 how much do you wanting  this is a bizarre conversation 10 10 out  of 10  you